Picarones are a mix of sweet potatoes and squash,...
...flour and salt shaped and fried with syrup on top.
Enslaved African cooks who were brought to Peru by the Spaniards...
...created this delicious treat inspired by the Spanish bunuelos.
Though the spelling, pronunciation and exact recipe of this dessert...
...changes throughout the region,...
...kanafeh is traditionally a favorite amongst people in the Middle East.
Think shredded phyllo dough or semolina dough with melted cheese, cream or nuts...
...topped with sweet rose water syrup.
This stacked dessert features eight thin layers of dough...
...with dulce de leche sandwiched between, topped with whipped Italian meringue.
This dessert gets its name from alfajores,...
...Argentinian shortbreads that the dessert resembles.
The three colorful layers of che ba mau are the yellow mung beans, red beans...
...and the green agar jelly mixed with pandan,...
...which gives the jelly a chewy taste similar to a gummy bear.
Topped with crushed ice, condensed milk and coconut milk,...
...this dessert is not as sweet as you may think,...
...but it is refreshing and perfect for the hot days in Vietnam.